hi guys my name is tiara chambers and
this is how the room and this is
Halloween awesome comics and this is
Tara's never seen today we are watching
Walter calling me hello Elvis are you
guys watching it yes we're we're
watching meteor man oh my god you're
gonna love it I'm so excited yeah okay
Jackie you seem very good good one oh my
god so we were trying to find like a
comic or superhero movie kind of tied
into awesome comics and this and The
Crow none of us had ever seen I wanted
to keep it a little upbeat it doesn't
look like a crazy that happened
during the filming of The Crow so we
went with this video
Walter was super pushing for them for a
while we have the whole Avengers team
here we have wonderful internet and
Plotkin oh I didn't yeah I didn't get
the memo on the beach it's alright
I usually I'm a Marvel girl mouse over
the mm-hmm yeah Marvel world a lot my
nerdy t-shirts are stores
I like seven and some know superheroes
you can respect that
yeah thank you so yeah here we go sorry
about yelling to take off my glasses
because he has no secret identity
what's going on so it starts off on Jeff
yeah who is charming deadbeat substitute
question her teacher her exactly my
favorite Jeff seid is in the very
beginning where like the principal calls
again and she's like well look would you
go now Jeff and he's like Mark Wahlberg
and a happening
reason no he's like you know what's
better than that is the parents that are
like why you teach our Sunday youth
writer called violet got any news dad
who is like the opposite not a pushover
at all the family in general peers are
great and I love that they are so caring
about the community they're like yeah
we're gonna help the communities where
these cats Jeff goes through his band
he's also advanced young as substitute
teachers do cars out of gas
yeah I just about how much you touch
their lives yes yeah let's go borrow
money from Sarris he gets back they took
just radio and bass oh no Jeff no it was
just okay and he like picked up some
trash and throws it out here I kick
that's all I can do is recycle he kicks
to the alleyway where this woman is
being attacked
yeah right I you look who's attacking my
Logan she'll drag prison the golden Lord
hello
okay the entrance every time is the most
epic if your game does not enter with a
freaking slinky and a tiger get out of
my neighborhood I wonder if the tiger
had to do initiation too though rich I'm
sure he did have one here which is a
buzzing all right I mean everyone else a
lot here I just wrote is this real also
we're chanting they're like into bad
guys I do like Gorn Lord Louis hoping I
return to West Side Story
no one though so you find out they're
putting the students through initiation
that's when the kids were beating up
student boy now so they want you to
another Jeff Jeff Hinz in a trash can
you put them solely and right out
working alongside a resident and then
the kid lifted up hey is there anyone in
there nobody no slam I know he's name is
squirrel the youngest of the board
climbed out of a trash can sad broke
about time for him to get some super
power 15 minutes in yeah and nobody has
powers yeah ain't need you right that
just crashes into his chest and just
like a great hurry everywhere
I had so many questions when this was
happening why Jeff how is it how what
why how is this absorbing into his body
those are it that rolled off into
strange homeless man / well Cassie you
don't see him in that moment and I wrote
down so Jeff a stout and a dark figure
comes up to him as he's passed out
could this be Bill Cosby and if I was
making Jo uh Cosby allegations was uh
you can't get none because it was hit
because I'm not hold you guys on the
hair foot now yes Oh always one two
three oh okay oh god what color again he
wasn't with up are you still watching it
yeah well actually we're in the middle
of the review right now so did you know
because he's in it yes we know it's Bill
Cosby oh my god the Jo copper convicted
for the roof leave I mean it I mean it
joke about yes
okay yeah oh I'm just gonna let you go
now okay all right happiness okay - yeah
if you love Leland so he throws the
whole Hospital into its complete chaos
doctors are running everywhere like
you're beccasues blood sample of this
man find out his powers first power
reveals is the book power I pretend of
the book absorbs the powers for thirty
seconds not Howard looks at powerfully
yes not another way is now now get out
of ours yes I don't know why they chose
to show the x-ray vision as people in
their underwear
I think see anything is like except for
through interpreter when he looks down
at like everyone that's on like a smoke
break or whatever everyone's in their
lingerie and there's one guy in a button
up top and I was like one what material
is that does he not see through comes I
feel like that one what like that guy
didn't showed up the filming it was like
oh this is a scene we're doing today I
have this in my contract I can't I got a
weird thing I'm like that I need your
mail right no one knows what his powers
can do so it's okay I don't think it can
also see the walls but with a terribly
edited green ball I'm bad Walter you
added a weird green but we're outside of
these everyone lean
I thought is that oh my god he can
understand animal homie I hope we can
understand the tiger later he doesn't
say I got in like somebody's best use of
that power than I movie could have ever
done I know somebody at the end of
filming was like I don't know their only
budget we usually die very nice we
sought to be animals yeah weird like a
TR boys know what's going on like
someone so much so I guess like a that's
not without don't like okay I can I
cannot James Earl Jones is amazing wig
yeah yeah my kicks off the wind more
stream Malcolm hair which is great we
find out the jet has super strength
yeah next thing review right um because
his dad gets speed up and then the the
blondes mean guys show up again and I
love to start knocking jeb whole entire
neighborhood is out watching this happen
so right off of that jeff has no secret
no secret identity it's okay because
then his parents can tell everyone
anyway as their like a jojo's
neighborhood watch Judith or just super
cute how proud of them are his mom they
send like this super students and we go
to sweet like talking bats and montage
hope you guys have a favorite costume in
the montage because I definitely do the
camera lens do I have evidence now I do
bulletproof another powers can also jump
I slash fly we find out that he's afraid
of heights and I thought maybe that
combat leader in some kind of form no it
just means that whatever he's like he's
just hovering right above street level
he's like that in case I lose this I
don't want to like kill myself so
another superpower he looks like a
Brussels sprout in pictures oh yeah the
landlady does and that's who is scared
Jeb turns into media man yeah yeah and I
what a bad guys
it's our mom's veggies I'm sorry yeah I
would have dare to get speed up Nonna
when the landlady outfit with a fit plus
my dad's fine he's kind of a jackass I
hate him live my lady
no she's a nice lady
power breath okay show me exit key is
you can grow things yeah you make this
giant like but not only just like
grudging like you can make giant ass
things grow overnight make it rain
okay I'm not gonna dress literally she
makes it plain everything grows huge you
know they're example taken away huger's
of course there was even a Bill Cosby is
like hugging a giant tomato and then
you're like wait wait no Cosby this
movie yeah oh yeah that's why I wrote
the blog this would show up slinky dark
scary
aren't they though so many weird plots
with Sinbad as the newscaster girlfriend
one even one of my character I was not
buying into the stereotype I birthday
yesterday I was confused by it but
definitely intricate if anything you've
got super speed now oh yeah great can
you get this bread Michael dresses up as
media man like a stupid idiot and steals
the food yeah pick up chicks at the mall
nothing just do that at the mall yeah
just go to the ball another weird plot
point where it's like that was not
needed to the film at all so then the
the Lord shows me how could you did high
welfare less going on hey Tamara did you
guys get to the park yet with the gold
Laura shoot all his friends and you have
to save them I'm going really fast as a
and believe them is amazing well we're
just about to get to that part so yeah
mm-hmm Walter just let us grab this in
our own time Walter I just wanna okay
that's probably so anybody award you up
again no I mean he's like I've come to
send you a message blow well of love and
Jeff catches a little pores all right
I've come to mention a message that you
can't protect everyone off at all times
of the way they cover attacked every
watch it all got back we would like
something as he catches the ball as he
starts bleeding yeah I was I wasn't sure
if that meant like it was his blood or
if he caught it as it went through
and the neighborhood starts like turning
against him oh he doesn't have a showers
anymore let's just give him to the
Lord's and then they'll leave us alone
he is this amazing um like speech that
he gives to the community center
everybody complains about the police and
they are perfect but how can you
complain you do nothing oh yes yes
one of the most heartfelt seems the
opposite moment we all by any means look
comfortably ones that high and preesh
and about seven so there's like 50
people there just rlm he's got no power
as a mom thank you all the standing and
fighting women actually amazing as
pornography was great so Cosby Jesus is
happening and he like assemble his dog
squadron and they all go out the house
because a little Pelican a tidge with a
gun that's right 60 hours away that's
his big reveal soon and then children a
whole the whole neighborhood comes out
and starts like punching them there's a
huge like giant fight the record
throwing moment yeah do you love this
record King the head war guy which he
find out in his son I just diamond and
Jeff both grab the meteor Suge and both
get some power that's gonna spring camp
that for sure look I'm not about all
jackets or neuro is Bruce Lee Bruce
later on book sequence where that one
kid just apparently is cry badass so ok
so like so so he gets thrown through a
truck that has both in it yeah and
there's a Bruce Lee book yeah so she
just is able to like get all of his
Bruce Lee fighting skills for 30 seconds
that scene was longer than don't know I
got again so I got my the ball and I'm
thirties I try to time it yeah and by
the time I had the timer running it had
been 27 seconds and I was like oh and
huge muscle you've done up in sours and
yet he wasn't and so he tries to go back
and grab the book what book does he grab
fashion modeling oh yeah ah ah
it was a moment he did because
everything was going bad everyone is sad
and like usually were superhero movies
are just like did you guys was in tenth
time X this is like no we're gonna Papa
baby AHA so voguing and then they
certainly can actually handle best part
of the betadine out of the entire film
sailor parts 105 values so hard then
Simon throws a truck on jet dog just
like it's so mad he chose advices
supersuit oh is that on and then beats
the crap out of Simon absorbed to powers
because that's another power oh yeah I
bet if you tried out he can absorb the
powers did we know that you know I
thought always he broke now Bill Cosby
feels the job yeah yes which is very
sweet thank you Bill
thank you for that I guess really wraps
up quick here the whole international
like drug cartel shows up they're like
we're gonna kill you now and then the
game to be a what's the bless is a crit
right so I what happen what was that was
that the came in so earlier in his like
um crime-fighting yeah montage yeah she
like stopped the cops from like the
shooting but I might fight with the ball
to the crisp so it wasn't the Crips now
come to help him but they both came
together yeah since when guys good for
you yes this movie come here man we
wanted to just just like and then it
frees and I thought like something
frozen oh there's oh it's no credit oh
yeah man just see it was an absolute
light as well with her so we actually
love it
um please check out awesome comics i
yeah thank you to you lovely ladies
yeah I love this movie a lot yo I don't
know if I or when I would have lost it
otherwise so obviously now we will
always have meteor manly and when you
guys are feeling sad let's go watch the
Crone do you get I just can you love me
please he's like no I didn't know camera
no I'll a traitor I really you know what
the one who's losing some combat
happened 11 like literally just ever
offered in traumatically mad I didn't
see what I was younger wow I can imagine
the DeSoto sector oh my so I I'm not
surprised I didn't because kid oh hello
Walter because I like it
[Music]
bye-bye